I know the one day we need to focus and
she had to temp don't know me I'll just
be here with my breasts and boobs being
a girl is hold as possible
freakin Austrians like land down under
and you know she just dates the hottest
dudes of all time you don't date me
that's fine I get that but you're wrong
and I hate you let her date the
underwear models and the pro surfers
okay I'm sorry if we're real people
we're real so real we're the realest
people I know I'm sick of beautiful
people who don't have to work for their
beauty when I'm over here sweating my
balls off for all this beauty and you
can hardly tell some days I don't know
I'm not wearing underwear mmm what
happens when I preach ackie late no one
is going to pre okay I always do guys
let's let's just think of a flaw right
she's not perfect yes she's exactly what
we want to be raped by right yeah but
does she have the build to birth me my
Olympic triathlete son no now what those
giant cans and tapered waist I'm sorry
it's not gonna happen
ders she has the face of a god if I
looked directly at her I will pre my
pants you free a lot too you could fill
up an otter pops sleeve